TONIGHT'S HASHTAG WARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
AGAIN, LAST NIGHT WAS A
THRASHING IN THE SPORT OF
FOOTBALLING, FORCING PEOPLE TO
DOT UNTHINKABLE AT SUPER BOWL
PARTIES-- HAVE ACTUAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT THINGS.
WE DO NOT WANT THAT TO HAPPEN
AGAIN, WHICH IS WHY TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG IS
#SUPERBOWLIMPROVEMENTS,
#SUPERBOWLIMPROVEMENTS.
NOW, 115 MILLION PEOPLE DID
WATCH THE SUPER BOWL.
STILL THINK THERE ARE THINGS
THAT COULD BE IMPROVED ON.
EXAMPLES WOULD BRUNO ON MARS, OR
RED VELVET URINAL CAKES.
OR CONCUSSION CAMS-- OH, THAT
WOULD BE SO RAD.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK.
STARTING NOW, GO.
YES, DOUG?
>> STRIPPERS ON THE GOALPOST.
>> Chris: SURE, POINTS!
HERZOG?
>> MORE PENETRATION IN THE END
ZONE.
>> Chris: WHOA!
ALWAYS POINTS FOR THAT, MY
FRIEND.
MEGAN NEURINGER?
>> NOT FOOTBALL.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: WHAT?
THAT'S UNAMERICAN.
POINTS!
DOUG BENSON?
>> THE PLAYERS HAVE TO PUT ON A
HALFTIME SHOW.
>> Chris: OH, THAT WOULD BE
AMAZE-TASTIC.
POINTS.
YES, HERZOG?
>> MASCOT CANNON-- YOU SHOOT THE
MASCOT INTO THE STANDS.
(LAUGHTER)
MEGAN?
(BUZZER SOUNDING)
NO, SAY IT ANYWAY!
(BLEEP) THE BUZZER!
LET'S DO THIS!
>> JOE NAMATH NIP SLIP.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS, FOR SURE.
SETH HERZOG?
>> REPLACE COIN TOSS WITH PIE
EATING CONTEST.
IT MIGHT TAKE LONGER, BUT IT
WOULD BE MORE FUN.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
DOUG BENSON?
>> WEED?
(LAUGHTER)